and it's also the same thing women  didn't have access to education  they couldn't own property which means  that realistically it was you you could  typically remember back then it was  typical for people to get married young  so it was typical for them so so the the  reason was when you were married it was  you were looked at as one and that was  and typically women submitted to their  husbands and trusted their husbands with  their judgment women like tip so that's  why the property like the property thing  happened and same with the property it  was like like women still could own  properties if they did not get married